so we've already established that these
three definite integrals are going to be
equal to zero over slightly different
conditions let's keep on going and
remember the goal here is to make it
simple for us to find our fourier
coefficients in a few videos from now so
now let's try to figure let's think
about the definite integral from 0 to 2
pi
if we're taking the product of sine of m
t
times sine
of n
t
d t and we're going to think about it in
two different scenarios we're going to
think about
when
when m
does not equal n or m does not equal
negative n and really we care more about
this scenario because in the fourier
series we're going to be dealing with
positive integers not or or non-negative
integers i guess we could say but this
is going to be true for both of them and
we're going to see when this is true
this integral is going to be 0 when
that's true and it's going to be equal
to pi
when
m is equal to n or another way we could
write this actually let me write it this
way
this integral
this integral is equal to zero
when
when m
does not equal n
or
m does not equal negative n and we're
gonna we're gonna assume integers
when integers m does not equal n or m
does not equal negative n and then if m
if n is equal to m or vice versa we
could say that the integral from zero to
two pi
zero to two point let me do this in a
different color just because i think it
will look nice
so the integral from 0 to 2 pi if m is
equal to n we could write that as sine
of mt times sine of mt which is going to
be sine squared of mt dt we're going to
establish that this is going to be equal
to pi
now how we're going to do that
well we can rewrite this original thing
right over here
we can rewrite this original thing using
a product to sum formula so let's
actually do that
so rewriting this integral it's the
integral from 0 to 2 pi
and i can rewrite and this is just a
trig identity that i'm going to be using
this is the same thing as
1 half
times
one-half of
times cosine of m t
mt
minus
nt so we could write that as m
minus n
t
and then minus
cosine of m t plus n t or we could write
that as m
plus n
t and actually let me put parentheses
around these whole things so it's more
clear
what's going on this right over here is
just the product to some formula when
you're taking this the product or the
sign of two different things here and of
course this is going to be
d t
now if we use some of our just our
integration properties we can rewrite
all of this as being the integral
from 0 to 2 pi in fact we could put that
one half out front twice i'm going to
write this as
as i guess you say the difference of two
integrals two definite integrals so we
could have
this one half
let me
write it in that same color
that one half right over there
times cos times the definite integral
from 0 to 2 pi of cosine of
m minus n
t
dt
d t
minus and once again i'm just
distributing this one half so minus and
taking it out of the integrals
so
minus
one half
times the definite integral from
zero to two pi
and i'm gonna have a dt out here so let
me just write the dt out there in
magenta
of of cosine
of
m plus nt
m plus n
t
dt and this is a slightly different
shade of blue so let me color that in as
well so once again we get from that to
that just using our integration
properties you can distribute the
one-half and say okay the integral of
the difference is the same thing as the
difference of the integrals you could
take the one-half out of the integration
side and we get to this right over here
now what do we know about this in the
case in the case where
m and n are integers that either don't
equal each other or don't equal the
negatives of each other well they don't
equal each other don't equal to the
negatives of each other then this right
over here is going to be a non-zero
integer
non-zero
and this also is going to be a
non-non-zero
integer and so we already know that if
we're taking the definite integral of
cosine of m t dt from zero to two pi
where m is some non-zero integer where
the coefficient on t is a non-zero
integer that that integral is going to
evaluate to 0. but that's what we're
doing over here and it doesn't look
exactly the same but this is a non-zero
integer coefficient this is a non-zero
integer coefficient so this whole
integral is going to be zero this whole
integral is going to be zero and even if
you multiply it by one half you still
get a bunch of zeros so hopefully that
makes you feel good about that statement
right over here when m does not equal n
or m does not equal negative n this
whole thing is just going to evaluate to
zero that's going to be zero and that is
going to be 0.
now let's think about the situation
where m does equal n
and actually let me just delete this a
little bit so we have some space to work
with
so if we assume
actually let me keep that part there
so let me
keep all of that there
all right now if m is and actually i
even colored
so
if we assume
if we assume in the case of sine
sine squared of mt if we assume
if
m is equal to n then what happens here
remember this one thing i wrote in green
is just this top one where m is equal to
n if m is equal to n
well
what happens is this second integral
right over here this is still going to
be a non-non-zero
integer coefficient so that one is going
to still be zero based on what we just
argued but this right over here m minus
n that is going to be zero you're going
to have a zero coefficient there so it's
gonna be cosine of zero t well cosine of
zero t that's cosine of 0 regardless of
what t you have and cosine of 0 is going
to be equal to 1. and so everything in
the case where m is equal to n this
whole thing simplifies to the one half
times the integral
from 0 to 2 pi
and i could write
of 1 dt if we like
dt
remember this is the case where m is
equal to n
and so what is that going to be equal to
well that's going to be equal to
one-half
times
well the anti-derivative of one is just
t
so it's just going to be
evaluated at two pi
and zero and so that is going to be
equal to
one half we're doing the same color so
we can keep track of things
so that is going to be equal to one half
times two pi minus zero
two pi
minus zero well two pi minus zero is
just two pi so i could just write that's
one half times two pi which of course is
just going to be equal to pi so we just
said look when m is equal to n well if m
is equal to n that this first magenta
expression is the same thing as what i
wrote in green and so when m is equal to
n this integral that integral when m is
equal to n is going to be and that's the
same thing as sine squared of mt that is
going to be equal to
is going to be equal to pi